You know, when we picture a scientific breakthrough, we usually imagine like a solitary genius staring at a chalkboard, suddenly connecting all the dots.
Right. Yeah. The classic Einstein image.
Exactly. But lately, with the whole explosion of AI, that picture is completely changed. Now the hype tells us to picture a black box. You feed in a prompt and boom, out pops a fully formed paradigm shifting paper.
Oh, the famous autonomous AI scientist myth. It's, you know, it's this pervasive idea in the tech world right now that we can just hand the steering wheel over to a language model, go to sleep and wake up to find it has independently cured a major disease or, I don't
know, finally solved quantum gravity.
Right. And it sounds amazing, right? But today, we are looking at a brand new, just fascinating piece of work released literally today, October 1st, 2026, that completely shatters that myth.
Yeah, it really does.
We're taking a deep dive into a guest post by Harvard physicist Matthew Schwartz, and it's titled Clawed-Shaped Science. He released this alongside a really detailed technical paper introducing an open source toolkit called Boot Loops.
And it's a provocative drop, honestly, because Schwartz is arguing something deeply counterintuitive for a tech-heavy paper. He says that while these massive language models are phenomenally good at doing science, they are absolutely not scientists.
Which is a huge distinction. And that brings us to our mission today. We are going to cut through the noise, cut through the Silicon Valley hype, to figure out what AI is actually doing in the lab right now.
Yeah, exactly. To understand what AI can do, we first have to understand the reality of what it currently struggles to do.
Right. We need to see why the future of discovery might look less like a robot Einstein, you know, and more like a human conductor leading an AI orchestra. And of course, what that means for you in the future of human knowledge. OK, let's unpack this, because to understand why
this new boot loops toolkit is such a big deal today, we actually have to look back at what Schwartz was doing just six months ago.
And, I mean, six months is a lifetime in AI development.
It really is. Back in March 2026, Schwartz published a post called Vibe Physics. He essentially treated the AI, Claude, like a very strong, maybe second-year grad student. Right. He handed it a highly technical physics problem, something called
resumming the Sudakov shoulder. Now, before we go further, for those of us who, you know, don't spend our weekends doing particle physics, what on earth is a Sudakov shoulder?
Fair question. Without getting lost in the quantum weeds, it's a notoriously sticky calculation. It deals with how subatomic particles emit radiation when they collide. It involves really complex logarithmic math. Basically, it's the kind of
grueling multi-step calculation that makes physics graduate students want to pull their hair out.
Got it. So he gives this incredibly dense problem to Claude and the AI eventually solved it. But I mean, reading Schwartz's account, it sounded brutal.
Brutal is putting it mildly. Schwartz described it as a massive slog. To get that one calculation done, it took, get this, 110 separate drafts.
Oh, wow. Yeah. 110 drafts for one calculation.
Yeah. The AI required immense hand-holding, constant correction, and just total micromanagement from a human expert. Left to its own devices, it couldn't just autonomously walk through the problem.
Which led Schwartz to his core realization today. Looking back at that slog, he identified what physicists call an impedance mismatch. I love this concept, but I want to make sure I'm visualizing it right. It's essentially an engineering term,
right? For when two systems just don't play nicely together.
That's the essence of it, yeah. Think of it like trying to put a Formula One racing engine into a John Deere tractor. Both are incredible, highly engineered machines. They work perfectly for their intended purposes, but their fundamental mechanics are just completely misaligned.
Right. They don't fit.
Exactly. The energy from that high-speed engine doesn't transfer efficiently to the heavy, slow-moving wheels of the tractor. It's a mismatch of physical properties.
So in this case, the tractor is the way human researchers naturally work, our step-by-step logic, our scientific intuition. And the Formula One engine is what the AI actually excels at.
Yes, exactly.
So instead of forcing the AI to act like a human physicist, Schwartz decided to stop fighting the mismatch. He started looking for what he calls clod-shaped problems, problems that naturally fit the AI's weird alien capabilities.
And doing that requires a total shift in how we view the tool. We have to stop asking, how can this AI do my job? And start asking, what tasks is this system naturally built to obliterate?
I'm tracking with you, but, well, let me push back on this a bit. Because this brings to mind that massive field experiment done by Delacroix and the BCG consultants back in, what, 2023?
Yes, the jagged technological frontier.
Right. They found that AI capabilities create this jagged frontier. Some highly complex tasks are weirdly easy for AI, while other seemingly simple logic tasks are completely outside its grasp. So is this whole idea of finding clod-shaped problems
just a convenient recipe for staying safely inside that jagged frontier? Are we just avoiding the hard stuff where AI naturally fails so we can pretend the technology is flawless?
That's a very sharp critique, and it's a trap a lot of researchers fall into, honestly. If you just stick to the safe zones inside that frontier, you're not actually advancing science.
Right. You're just doing expensive parlor tricks.
Exactly. But Schwartz's bet is completely different. He argues that the real scientific payoff isn't safely inside the center of any single discipline. The payoff is actually in the empty spaces between human disciplines. He calls this the convex
hull of human knowledge.
The convex hull. Okay, I need to visualize this. If human knowledge is this big jagged shape with spikes reaching out in different directions, like a spike for theoretical physics over here and a spike for evolutionary biology over there, is the convex hull
what you get if you stretch a giant rubber band around the outer tips of all those spikes?
That is the absolute perfect way to picture it. The convex hull is the empty space connecting those isolated peaks. Human experts are incredibly specialized. You might have a researcher who has spent 20 years mastering one specific set of genetic markers using one
specific mathematical method. Right. Meanwhile, a completely different field, say fluid dynamics, has developed a mathematical tool that perfectly solves that geneticist's problem.
But neither field talks to each other.
Never. The conferences are different. The journals are different. The vocabulary is different. Almost no single human expert knows both fields deeply enough to make the connection. But AI's true superpower isn't deep, solitary reasoning. Its superpower is near unlimited
breadth.
Because it has read the foundational literature of every field.
Exactly.
So instead of trying to make the AI invent a brand new theory from scratch, you use it to port an existing method from one discipline over to a problem in a completely unrelated discipline.
Yeah, that's the core idea.
But wait, how do you actually do that in practice? Because we already established that if you just ask Claude to do the math, it hallucinates or it takes 110 drafts to get it right.
And this is the brilliant part. This is why Schwartz and his team built Boot Loops. Boot Loops is the engine designed specifically for this clod-shaped science. It is an open-source, model-agnostic, living harness.
Living harness, meaning you can plug it into clod or GPT or whichever language model is currently state-of-the-art.
Right.
But what is actually inside this harness?
It's essentially a massive toolbox of highly specialized, deterministic computer programs. These are tools that always produce the exact same mathematical output given the same input. So no guessing. No language generation.
Okay, so hard math.
Yeah, hard math. To give you an idea of the depth here, Boot Loops includes tools for integral reduction using a program called CURA. It uses auxiliary mass flow techniques. It utilizes algorithms known as PSLQ and LLL for integer
relation fitting. And crucially, it employs a tool called ARB for ball and interval arithmetic alongside systems for exhaustive enumeration.
Okay, my head is spinning a little. Let's translate some of that. What do those tools actually do for the AI?
Let's break it down. Take Arb, for instance. When computers do massive calculations, they have to round decimals. Over millions of steps, those rounding errors compound until the final answer is completely wrong.
Like a snowball effect?
Right. Arb tracks those rounding errors with absolute precision so they don't spiral out of control. Kira is a program that takes impossibly complex mathematical integrals and systematically reduces them into simpler, solvable pieces. Got it. And exhaustive
enumeration literally means the computer physically checks every possible configuration of a problem to prove an answer is correct.
So it's like an architect who's full of creative ideas, but they're given a team of robot contractors who physically cannot measure a board incorrectly.
Yes. Great analogy.
So the AI has this toolbox, but how does it actually use it? Does it just press a button?
Not quite. The AI acts as an incredibly fast coder and orchestrator. It looks at a scientific problem, decides which tools in bootloops are needed, and writes the specific Python scripts or code to string those tools together. Oh, wow. And they didn't just use off-the-shelf
software, by the way. The team wrote roughly 100 brand new programs just to handle the computation of Feynman integrals alone.
That is a staggering amount of custom engineering.
It really is. But all of this relies on one ironclad rule that makes bootloops work. And this is key. The language model never supplies a digit.
Hold on. Never. Not one number in the final equation.
Not a single one. The language model writes the code to connect the tools. But the deterministic programs inside bootloops, like Arb and Kira, are the things actually crunching the numbers. And on top of that, every closed-form mathematical solution it finds
has to pass an independent, high-precision acceptance test.
Oh, I see. So if the AI tries to confidently hallucinate a mathematical answer in the middle of a process, the deterministic tool just acts like a brick wall and rejects it.
Exactly.
The math is either mathematically proven to be right or it's wrong. There is no vibe involved anymore.
Precisely. It forces the AI to rely on rigorous traditional computation for the actual answers, while using its language skills to plan the route, write the connective code, and interpret the outcome.
Here's where it gets really interesting. Because once they built this system, the sheer scale of the output it generated was unlike anything I've ever seen. We're talking about a three-month period. They worked through about 400 candidate problems.
Yeah, the volume is crazy.
And from that, they produced 36 manuscripts across 18 different fields with 19 human co-authors.
The velocity is just staggering. And the payoff in physics alone justifies the whole project. Using boot loops, they bootstrapped 30 Feynman integrals. Now, for context, Feynman integrals are the incredibly dense mathematical formulas used in particle
physics to predict what happens when you smash protons together at close to the speed of light.
So the large Hadron Collider stuff.
Right. Now, 15 of the integrals they calculated were reproductions of known, incredibly difficult calculations. They did that just to prove the boot loop system works.
Okay. Testing it out.
But the other 15 had never been computed before by human beings. We are talking about mapping highly complex geometries, things physicists call elliptic cases, K3 surfaces, and Calabi-Yau manifolds.
For you listening, Calabi-Yau manifolds are these hyper-complex, multidimensional shapes that theoretical physicists use to try and understand string theory. They are almost impossible for the human brain to truly visualize.
Yeah. Solving just one of these would normally take a PhD student years of grinding computation. Boot Loops was churning them out. But because of that convex hole effect we talked about, the AI didn't just solve physics problems and stop.
Right, the breath part.
Exactly. Because it has read everything, it started seeing this underlying math everywhere. And this led to an absolute aha moment in the research. The AI realized that these Feynman integrals used in quantum particle physics are structurally the exact same
mathematical objects as Bayesian evidence integrals used in phylogenetics.
Phylogenetics. Mapping the evolutionary family tree of species using DNA.
Yes, the complex math used to track subatomic particle debris is structurally identical to the math used to figure out the exact evolutionary divergence point between, say, a chimpanzee, an orangutan, and a human.
That is mind-blowing.
It's like realizing that the hyper-complex, top-secret blueprint for a spaceship engine perfectly solves a broken espresso machine in a totally different building. The physics tools just cleanly ported over to evolutionary biology.
And because boot loops already had the rigorous physics solvers built in, it could instantly evaluate these biological evolutionary trees exactly.
Wow. Biologists usually have to rely on messy statistical estimations because the math is just too hard. Boot loops just solve them.
But, you know, we need to pause here and take a breath. Because speed and perfect math do not automatically equal good science.
Oh, absolutely not.
I think we sometimes forget that. Just because an AI finds a correct answer doesn't mean it's an answer that human beings actually care about or can use.
And this is where Schwartz's impedance mismatch rears its head again in a big way. And it highlights the absolute necessity of keeping human scientists deeply involved in the loop.
Yes, let's walk through the forest ecology case study from the paper, because this perfectly illustrates your point. Schwartz teamed up with a plant biologist named James O'Dwyer to look at data from Barrow, Colorado Island. It's a tropical forest in the Panama Canal,
and it is arguably the most intensely studied plot of forest on Earth. Now, there's a concept in ecology called neutral theory. It basically asks a baseline question. How much of a forest's life and death cycle is just pure random chance?
If you ignore the species of the tree, just look at the math, what is the random baseline?
Right. And 20 years ago, an ecologist named Rampal Etienne wrote a brilliant equation for this. But the math was so horrifyingly complex that no one could actually solve it at scale for a real forest.
Enter Claude and bootloops. The AI recognizes the equation, realizes it has the physics tools to solve it, and crunches the data for the Barrow, Colorado forest. And this is where it matters to everyday people. Understanding
forest turnover is crucial for predicting how ecosystems will survive climate change or how to manage agricultural land.
The math comes back flawless. The AI proves that the forest turns over, meaning trees die and new ones take their place, 4.5 times faster than neutral theory allows. The AI essentially throws its hands up and says, look, I solved the 20-year-old
equation.
But when Schwartz proudly took this mathematically perfect result to a Dwyer, the ecologist's reaction was essentially a shrug. He was completely unimpressed. He literally said ecologists would just shrug at this because they already knew it
qualitatively. Anyone who studies forests already knows that real trees grow and die faster than a purely random mathematical model. The AI's result was technically correct, but scientifically completely unmoving. It didn't push the field forward in a
way that mattered.
And that is the crux of the issue. The real science only happened because O'Dwyer, the human, redirected the AI. Okay. He looked at it and said, okay, the neutral prediction is mathematically sound now. Let's subtract that neutral prediction from our actual
data and model what is left over. Because the leftover data exposes the actual real-world biology. That's where you see the natural selection, the competition for sunlight, the specific life histories of different tree species.
Oh, I see. They used the AI's rigorous mathematical baseline to clear away the noise exposing the actual ecology underneath. And together they built a minimal, highly accurate predictive model of the forest. Exactly. And what's
fascinating is this exact pattern repeated over and over in the paper. Claude would produce something technically flawless. The human expert would be totally unmoved. And together, they would reshape it into real science. They did it with genetics and gene
conversion with Michael Desai. They did it in economics, all over the map.
Which perfectly aligns with the broader research on human-AI collaboration. If you look at the 2026 paper by Li and colleagues on AI versus human scientists, they found this exact division of labor. When it comes to theory building, AI and humans have
complementary strengths. AI supplies immense computational breadth that can scan a thousand fields and build massive, complex structural theories. But human scientists supply the parsimony. They supply the direction. And most importantly, they supply what Schwartz
calls taste.
Taste. The intuition for what is actually interesting and meaningful. Because the AI completely lacks it. Schwartz is very explicit about the AI's failure modes in this work. Even with the boot loop's harness, Claude will frequently declare
victory way too early.
Oh yeah, constantly.
It will find one unproven lemma, like one tiny stepping stone of a proof, and confidently claim the entire grand theory is finished.
It also has absolutely no sense of time or sunk costs.
None. It will blindly grind away at a dead-end mathematical problem for hours instead of taking a step back and realizing, wait, I just need to write a better software tool for this. It needs the human handler to step in and say, stop computing, start building.
This raises an important question for the broader scientific community. Are we risking the overall quality of our science by confusing an AI's raw computational power with actual scientific intuition?
That's a great point.
We see headlines about AI solving problems, and we assume it's doing the intellectual heavy lifting, but it's really doing the mechanical heavy lifting, albeit at an unprecedented cross-disciplinary scale.
Yeah, we have to take a step back and look at the broader context of these claims. And in the spirit of full, impartial disclosure to you, the listener, we need to point out a few structural tensions in the source material we're discussing today. First, Matthew Schwartz is a
visiting researcher who is funded by Anthropic, which is the company that makes Claude.
Right. Furthermore, this essay, Claude-Shaped Science, is hosted directly on Anthropic's own corporate science blog.
Exactly. And while the output is massive, we have to note that most of those 36 manuscripts generated in those three months are preliminary preprints. They have not yet gone through formal independent peer review. We are impartially reporting what is in the text, but
you should keep the source and the preliminary nature of the work in mind when evaluating the claims.
That being said, what makes Schwartz's perspective so interesting is how actively it pushes against the hype his own funders might typically benefit from.
Right. He's not selling the robot scientist.
No, he is directly challenging the autonomous AI scientist narrative. He's rejecting the idea that AI is going to independently win millennium prizes without human supervision.
He explicitly calls that narrative a foot gun, like a great way to shoot your own research in the foot by trusting the AI to operate without a human pilot.
If we connect this to the bigger picture, Schwartz's thesis is fundamentally about workflow. AI does not collapse the scientific method into a single magical prompt. Rather, AI sits inside the scientific loop.
Right.
It augments the incredibly tedious process of acquiring data, running the complex math, checking the code, and stepping forward. It is a spectacular power tool, not a replacement for the craftsman.
So to quickly recap our journey today, we started with the agonizing hand-holding of vibe physics just six months ago, where Claude needed 110 drafts to do one calculation.
A nightmare.
Truly. We explored how Schwartz solved that impedance mismatch by building boot loops, ensuring the model never supplies a digit, and targeting those Claude-shaped problems in the convex hole between disciplines. We saw how it magically linked quantum
particle physics to primate family trees.
Yeah.
And we saw, through the forest ecology example, that while AI brings unmatched computational breadth, human beings are desperately needed to supply the taste, the direction, and the actual meaning.
And that reality leaves us with some profound, unresolved questions for the future of academia. Schwartz points out that in this new paradigm, he honestly doesn't know how to train graduate students anymore. If bootloops can do all the coding and the grueling math,
what exactly is the entry-level work that teaches a Yang student how to be a scientist?
Right. If the traditional hazing ritual of doing 100 integrals by hand is gone, how do they ever develop that human taste?
Furthermore, who actually gets the credit for this clod-shaped science? We risk a situation where the senior researcher gets all the glory and the hands-on prompting, curating, and AI-wrangling work is dismissed as just typing. And practically speaking, why would a
researcher write a grueling three-year grant proposal for a problem that an AI model with bootloops might solve over a single weekend?
The pace of the technology is just completely outstripping our human institutions. It's thrilling, but it's incredibly disruptive. And that leaves us with one final thought for you to mull over today. If the real, untapped power of AI
lies in the convex whole of human knowledge, its unique ability to connect completely isolated islands of expertise, what about your own life? What two completely unrelated fields in your own work, your hobbies, or your
background might secretly hold the exact answers to each other's problems? Just waiting for you to find the right tool to connect them. Until next time, keep diving deep.